نواصل مع تطورات في ملف حرب روسيا على
اوكرانيا حيث اعلن حاكم خركيب الاوكراني
مقتل شخصين في قصف للقوات الروسيه استهدف
مناطق عده في المدينه خلال الساعات الاربع
والعشرين الماضيه
باسم قياده عمليات الجنوب في الجيش
الاوكراني ان شخصين قتلا واصيب اكثر من
عشرين في قصف روسي استهدف المدينه خلال
الساعات الماضيه واض
وزاره الدفاع الروسيه قالت ان قوتها شنه
الليله الماضيه غاره على منشات يتم فيها
التحضير لاعمال وصفها بالارهابيه في اوديس
من جهته وزير الخارجيه الاوكرانيه اكد ان
الهجوم على اوديسا هو الاكبر على ميناء
حيوي للامن الغذائي العالمي وحصل وزير
الاوكراني جميع الدول والمنظمات على ادانه
ما وصفها بجريمه الحرب الوحشيه الروسيه
على اوديسا من جهاته توعد الرئيس
الاوكراني
بالرد على الهجوم ووصفه بالارهابي